[MUSIC PLAYING]
INTERVIEWER 1: This picture
shows a pair of Kazakh Golden
Eagle Hunters, but that title
is actually a bit misleading.
The eagle in the picture
isn't a prisoner, or the pray,
this golden eagle is
actually the hunting tool.
INTERVIEWER 2: Hi, my
name is David Baxendale,
I'm a professional travel
photographer based in Glasgow,
in Scotland.
The photograph
you are looking at
was taken in the Altai Mountains
of Mongolia in July, 2004.
There are thousands
and thousands
of square miles of absolutely
no people, no roads,
no electricity, no
cellphones, it's
an incredible area to visit.
INTERVIEWER 1: But
the landscape isn't
the only fascinating
thing about the area.
David traveled to this
remote part of Asia
to learn about the people,
and their way of life.
INTERVIEWER 2: The Kazakh
people, and their traditions,
are incredibly
hospitable, warm people.
Obviously nomadic, and they
move maybe three times a year
with the gers, in
the mountain areas.
If you ever visit the area, you
get a very, very warm welcome.
They have an open door
policy on the gers,
and anyone can just
literally walk in, sit down,
and you'll be immediately
given food and drink.
I lived alongside them
for about a week in 2014,
and I was able to walk with
them on a ridge with a eagle
at dusk, and that
photograph was taken
along the walk with the bird.
INTERVIEWER 1: One of the
world's largest birds of prey,
golden eagles are
extremely important
to the nomadic Kazakh
hunters, because
of their extreme environment
that they live in.
INTERVIEWER 2: The
landscape vast,
and obviously, the
animals and the prey
move rapidly, they're
faster than horses,
so I think the idea is to
use eagles to catch the prey,
because they're much
faster, and they
can make a kill a lot easier.
INTERVIEWER 1: And when David
says faster, he means it.
A golden eagle can reach speeds
up to 200 miles per hour,
which is no match
for the animals
that Kazakh people rely on.
INTERVIEWER 2: The eagles
are used to hunt, primarily,
foxes, wolves, marmoths, which
the hunters obviously use
for food in the harsh winters.
They also use the fur from
the animals for clothing,
and I think, in
the photograph, you
can see that they're wearing
clothes that they captured
from wolves or a fox.
INTERVIEWER 1: And even though
he spent only a week there,
David knew the impact
the golden eagles have
on the people of
the Altai Mountains.
INTERVIEWER 2: The
region, itself,
is absolutely incredible.
It's one of the last
true wildernesses
in the world, huge
mountains 4,000 meters high,
and snow-capped
glaciers are everywhere,
and obviously, it's the
land of the golden eagle.
iNTERVIEWER 1:
"this happened HERE"
aims to share compelling images
and the stories behind them.
If you liked this video,
be sure to check out
this one to see what
it's like to dive
into a humpback whale fight.
INTERVIEWER 3: This
is an image moments
after this juvenile humpback
whale took a sharp turn
to avoid smashing in to me.
INTERVIEWER 1:
Thanks for watching.